around the world aid is starting to flow
to lebanon
pallets of medical supplies loaded onto
planes in france
with rescue teams readying themselves to
join the search for survivors it's
feared there are still many people
trapped under the twisted metal and
debris from the blast
the french president emmanuel macron
will arrive here later
as a show of solidarity a sign of
support
from one of this nation's closest allies
the explosion is something no one here
will forget
ever bride israel sablani
was posing for her wedding photos when
the explosion
ripped through the streets around her
24 hours later she returned to the same
spot
with her husband safe but shaken by the
experience
i feel so sad about what happened to
other people
about what happened to lebanon when i
when i woke up and i saw the damage that
happened to beirut
i realized the one thing i said was
alhamdulillah we're still alive
there is a resilience here the people
shaped
and hardened on the forge of conflict
but this was something else
even years of shelling car bombs and
endless war
are no preparation for what appears to
be a random explosion
of titanic proportions
and as people come to terms with the
damage the authorities say they've
placed a number of port officials under
house arrest
whilst investigators try to understand
who was responsible for the storage of
the ammonium nitrate
that caused the blast
last night with the city plunged into
darkness
the security forces went out onto the
streets
the government's declared a two-week
state of emergency
the authorities are now saying that more
than half the city has been damaged by
the blast now
countless families are having to spend
another night outside in the sweltering
heat this area is normally an area of
protest and there is a great deal of
anger here
but for the moment they're gathering to
bring in humanitarian aid
which they're hoping to distribute in
the coming hours
hayat nazir is gathering bedding
it's basic but better than nothing
she blames the government for this
catastrophe
i have one one concern that if other
countries are going to help
lebanon and if they're going to give the
money to the government then it's like
they're giving money
to those who destroyed us and killed us
they will steal the money
lebanon is now a country with crisis
piled upon crisis economic collapse
political meltdown covert 19
and now this the smoking crater of the
port
asphyxiating a city which is already
drowning in debt
and corruption alex rossi
sky news beirut